House Democrats are issuing new
subpoenas in their impeachment inquiry
into President Trump
yesterday they demanded documents from
Energy Secretary Rick Perry regarding
his knowledge of president Trump's phone
call where he asked Ukraine's president
to investigate Joe Biden and his son now
they also subpoena two Associates of the
president's personal lawyer that's Rudy
Giuliani after the men were arrested for
allegedly violating campaign finance
laws the White House sent a letter to
top congressional Democrats earlier this
week saying the administration will not
cooperate until the inquiry is
formalized with a floor vote a lot going
on 60 minutes correspondent John
Dickerson is with us to break down
everything that has happened this week
in Washington good to see you John
Dickerson good to be back Gail good to
see you it seems like every day there is
a jaw-dropping moment where we start we
talk amongst ourselves and say can you
believe fill in the blank just happened
and now lately I've been hearing words
like constitutional crisis is it that
serious or should people just calm down
take a beat right well and it was so
quiet before this so I think depends
where you start on the Constitution I
think Constitution is getting a stress
test so if you think the Constitution
which in and it was arranged this way
was to basically adjudicate fights so
the people wouldn't take their fights
out into the street well there's a fight
going on yeah if the Constitution can
handle it
at the end of this process if everybody
gets their say then things are okay and
it's not a crisis the problem is if the
Constitution and the separation of
powers is set up in a way that it
doesn't get adjudicated then you're in a
true crisis one little thing to remember
that is that Benjamin Franklin when he
rolled out impeachment as an idea in
that summer 1787 it was to exonerate the
president as much to kick out a
president we've long forgotten that but
in that concept the Constitution can
still handle this so far the White House
has decided to take a strategy of
resisting what do you make of that
strategy
well it's familiar to them and also
familiar to white houses which is resist
resist and that gives you better
negotiating terms for witnesses for all
kinds of other things the problem upside
for the White House is when there's
delay it makes you can beat the other
side into looking unprofessional Adam
Schiff had some problems when he said
things that were not so about being in
touch with the whistleblower on the
other hand it also gives an opportunity
for this daily drumbeat of serious news
to come
you have serious career professionals
saying that a disordered white house led
to a process where US foreign policy was
undermine by essentially a rogue
operation and that puts national
security at risk and sends a daily
picture of chaos and it's why 17% in the
Fox poll said the president did
something that wasn't right that's not
good numbers for the president and
that's what happens when you have this
daily drumbeat how does it compare to
the proceedings the impeachment
proceedings of Nixon and Clinton I think
a lot of people aren't clear exactly you
can be impeached and you could still
stay in office well you you you can and
we should think of impeachment and then
also the coming election yeah as you can
you can the impeachment can go its route
but also the president has to worry
about his political fortunes going
forward and whether people decide they
want four more years of highly
improvisational White House and we see
improvisation crashing against the
system that what's different this time
is you have more partisanship although
you know in more of this time well you
you have a country that has sorted more
partisan than it now it was highly
partisan in Nixon and Clinton and in the
the dam breaks at the end of Nixon but
for a long time a lot of Republicans
stayed with him but you have a more
partisan country and you have a
dispersal of channels of communication
you know during Nixon you had three
networks some would say there was really
only one Network time Gale but you had a
sort of common set of facts now
everybody can go to their corners you
have social media which not only allows
different information but allows a kind
of tribal response to things so that
people just talk past each other and
that destroys institutions is not just
about whether impeachment gets
adjudicated but it's whether the
institutions that we used to rely on get
burned down in the process a lot of
people but you do make a good point
about different set of facts because
watch one network and feel something
watch a net another network and feel
another different way but aren't there
really only one set of facts yes a bite
sometimes takes a minute or two to get
to them and sometimes people in the
interim while those facts are being
worked out by a process long ago set up
it's it's in their interest to undermine
the institutions looking into them by
saying the FBI and the CIA and the house
are all are all compromised somehow what
that does is it not only hurts the
ability to get to the facts but it
the next time you could try to go get to
the facts everybody thinks those
institutions are worthless and that's
when you lead to chaos that's when you
have a constitutional you meant you
mentioned the Fox poll a lot of people
compare this obviously to the
impeachment during the Watergate era
Nixon by the time impeachment came
around was actually he had very high
negatives didn't he yeah he was at about
20% by the time at the very very end but
you you you know parties rally and and
and the wait the way opinion changes
really is when you get what the
political science is called Parra's
Matic dissenters which is to say
somebody who is a fan of the president's
not a never Trump er somebody who is on
the president's team finally saying
whether it's with respect to Syria
whether it's respect to Ukraine or
anything else saying you know this is
too much but right now that's not
happening Republicans are very happy
with this president still because of tax
cuts regulation judges defense spending
taking on China he has done more for a
lot of Republicans than they say any
Republican has done since Ronald Reagan
he's got very strong support still in
his party although obviously it's
weakening with some of these new
impeachment polls do you have a
one-sentence on where this is heading
keeping people up at night not towards
stability there will be more instability
all right good to know thank you John